revit has come under fire in the press
lately and today we're going to talk
about
revit versus architects
what's going on guys my name is david
thomage and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about the open
letter addressing the concerns of
revit users predominantly in the uk
if you aren't aware already 17 out of 25
firms publicly put their name forward
to the ceo of autodesk which is the
parent company of revit
to say that there are many problems that
they need to address
publicly more so than privately because
clearly
revit and autodesk are not listening to
these concerns during private
conversations
some of these firms are the world's
absolute best architectural firms
including grimshaw and zaha hadid
architects
if you don't know who these two firms
are quickly google them and you'll be
shocked at what they've done
they produce some of the absolute best
masterpieces that we have in our
generation between the 25 firms that
allowed their names to be on the list
and didn't allow their name to be
publicly addressed these firms hold
a total of 5 000 licenses or an
equivalent
of 22 million dollars worth of annual
revenue for autodesk so what's the
problem what are these firms
really looking for well i've read the
letter in great detail i've read all the
articles that go with it
and i've also read the responses from
autodesk basically
what these firms really want is revit to
improve
they're not looking for anything else
but
the improvement of the actual platform
itself most of these companies feel like
the architectural section of revit has
been pushed to the side for the past
couple years
whilst autodesk has focused on the
engineering side of it
another factor that many of them are
concerned about is the continual
growth of price per year over the last
five years there have been
five different pricing platforms that
companies have had to adopt to
revvit has gone from a very basic
pricing model
to a very complicated pay-per-year
annual recurring fee
some of these customers are even saying
that their costs
for revit alone has gone up 70 percent
now i don't know about you guys but if
somebody put up the price by
70 over a number years i would be pretty
upset as well
businesses have to run on very tight
margins
and architectural programs not just
revit but everything that goes along
with the suite of running an
architectural
firm is a huge chunk of your overheads
the main reason they're concerned about
the price increase isn't actually to do
with the fact that it's getting more
expensive
it's more so to do with the fact that
revit is no longer innovating
autodesk is no longer innovating they
have stopped
putting all their eggs into the
architectural basket and started taking
them all out into the engineering side
of things
it has been a very long time since
architecture
has had the main focus of the update
there's been no
innovations to save time to further
innovate
it's just been stale and stagnant for a
couple years
whilst the costs have continued to go up
so these architectural firms have not
been able
to justify the increasing price without
having a major update
that comes along with it it would be
absolutely fine
if every year something major change in
revit to either save you time
save you money or save something along
the way
instead it's just making things more and
more complicated
as designs get more and more complex
these firms are also finding that the
salespeople of autodesk are pushing
these products on them
now as a cause of this there's been a
lack of trust
the users of revit no longer trust the
system
and trust the manufacturer being
autodesk they're very worried now about
what's going to happen
as autodesk continues to transition to
the cloud
how secure is their data going to be who
is able to access this data
what is that data going to be used for
besides from just inside their actual
firm
now as we know privacy and data is a
very very hot topic
in 2020 and has been for the past decade
the more the data gets leaked the more
that information gets out that shouldn't
be out there
the more we crack down on privacy and
data settings
now this is a very fair concern from
these companies
imagine if you had just spent hundreds
of millions of dollars
setting up a massive architectural firm
setting up
all of your templates all of your
libraries
absolutely everything and somebody was
able to access one of your files
those hundreds of millions of dollars
you just spent
somebody stole for free basically offer
you
that isn't a very good feeling and that
is a very real concern
for these big firms out there now these
firms are looking
to rebuild the trust to rebuild the
relationship with autodesk
because obviously they have spent
hundreds of millions of dollars
training their staff building their
platforms building their templates
they're not going to jump ship no matter
what the price of revit
actually goes up to they really want to
be open and transparent with this
company
to make sure it continues to progress
and excel
because if it doesn't then the companies
are going to get stale
stagnant and they're not going to be
able to be these award-winning firms
that they are today
they basically asked autodesk to provide
a roadmap of what the future looks like
what they can expect and how they are
going to innovate
more and more each year now autodesk was
very quick to respond
to this open letter obviously they had
to protect their assets and they had to
protect their company
so they came out firing they were not
happy with some of the comments
but they also agreed with some of the
points made
ever since the first release they've
released an additional two statements
totaling three statements at this point
in time
addressing the concerns that these
companies have put together
one of the main points that i actually
took from the these responses is the
fact
that autodesk or revit has actually
openly admitted
that they have focused a lot of their
time energy
and money into the engineering and
construction side of things forever
they've put the architectural systems on
the back burner
because they felt that it was very well
developed and this other area
needed improvement which yes is
definitely true
but when most of your customer base is
architectural you still need
to reward those guys for staying with
you and building
such a great platform and such a great
software what they didn't say though
is that they will actually put some
active effort back into the
architectural industry
they've just said yes we're focused on
engineering
and construction because that's where
the future is so i don't know how
effective this letter is going to be at
pushing those updates quicker into the
software i have a feeling that revit is
going to continue to focus on
engineering and construction
because that's where the future they see
is the ceo directly responded saying
that they will talk
personally and privately with the 17
companies that made their name public
which means the 17 companies are going
to score some sort of deal behind the
scenes cut their costs
and try and get in on a ground floor to
these new innovative products
what it also means is only those 17
companies
are going to have those discussions with
the ceo and with autodesk
the rest of the users that use revit
well they're going to see the effects
10 20 years down the track now maybe
reading into the comments of the
cloud-based
response a little bit too much but
basically what the ceo stated in direct
response to the concerns
of the autodesk users was the simple
fact that
revit and autodesk are meeting the
minimum standards
for cloud-based services the minimum
standards
doesn't mean you're actively trying to
defend
people's privacy it means you're just
kind of
scraping by to be able to produce that
product and be
in that space i'm hoping to see the
cloud-based software
really take a new leg forward and really
leap
because cloud-based software is
definitely the future
and if privacy becomes a concern it can
[ __ ] a company
it could be a matter of days before
revit goes from
the absolute pinnacle and best software
in the industry
to a company that's absolutely bankrupt
because somebody has leaked all the
information from their cloud
that would be a huge blow to the
industry as a whole
autodesk also published a roadmap of
what the future looks like
for revit in 2021 and 2022
now this is something that they do every
year so it wasn't
really like they went out of their way
to showcase all their new features that
are in development and they're thinking
about producing and making
they're just being open and transparent
as they have always been
in the past i don't think that's what
the
signatories of the open letter really
wanted
i think that they wanted more
reassurance
to know that the future is going to be
focused on architecture
in the open road map unfortunately when
you scroll through it
you will see that yes architecture is
getting a little bit of an upgrade
but it is again very very heavily
focused on
engineering and construction a point i
did find in the roadmap was revit was
really pushing to move away
from a desktop only program they're
trying to make the future
more mobile that means cloud-based
systems that can run on mobiles
tablets basically anywhere this would be
a very very good innovative step for
architecture
architects engineers absolutely
everybody that uses the software
it was pretty well hidden in that road
map
but they're definitely talking about
moving away from the desktop only system
and being able to document design on any
platform
overall what are my thoughts well i
think these companies have a right to be
upset
they're paying a premium for one of the
best software's in the world
unfortunately they're not getting the
best software and the best
customer service in return i would be
upset
if i was paying hundreds of thousands of
dollars per year to a company
and not getting my money's worth however
at the same time
i see it from a business point of view
as well autodesk is a giant company
they're a world leader in the industry
and they want to dominate and continue
dominating
which means from a business point of
view and a marketing point of view
sometimes you have to shelf one idea to
make the other one
grow and in this case that is exactly
what happened
they shelved architecture to make sure
engineering and construction
became just as powerful and made the
software even better than what it is
today
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that like
button to help this video with the
algorithm
and if you want to see more of my
content make sure you smash that
subscribe button 2020 style
and as always i'll see you next monday